- 'Cause I feel like everybody
always treats actors like,
as they probably should,
emotional, like, landmines,
everybody is like tiptoeing
around because you never know
what's going to set them off,
and it's just a job, like any other.
You look how you look, and be comfortable.
Like what are you going to
do, be hungry every single day
to make other people happy?
That's just dumb.
My childhood in my mind seems so lovely,
and just picturesque, and
then I talk back about it,
I'm like, "Oh my God."
- She's the highest paid
actress in the world
and her films have grossed
over five billion dollars.
She had her breakthrough in 2010
playing a poverty-stricken teenager
in the independent film "Winter's Bone."
In 2013, she was listed in Time Magazine's
100 Most Influential People in the World.
She's Jennifer Lawrence,
and here's my take
on her top 10 rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Jennifer's talking,
if she says something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(swoosh)
(dramatic music)
- Hi, I'm Jennifer Lawrence.
Have you been hiding under a rock?
How would you not know that.
I've always had this really
gross, dangerous mentality of,
no consideration of failure.
Just never even considering
the thought of failing,
like, if I want something
I just go until I get it.
And that doesn't always work, but.
- The interesting thing
for me to talk to you,
and what makes you so fascinating
is just the talent that
you see on the screen,
but at the same time,
there is a certain innocence
and yet a certain power,
and it seems to me it's both
artist and also business.
- Well thank you.
- [Charlie] Do you believe that?
- Yes.
- Am I right?
- I've worked very hard
to make that (laughs)
to make that true, so thank you.
- [Charlie] That it's both that.
- Thank you, because without gaining
some sort of control over the business
I lose some control over the creative,
which is most important.
- [Charlie] The more you
control the business,
the more you can give
flower to the creative.
- Exactly.
- [Charlie] Or give wings to the creative.
- Yeah, so I used to stay out of it.
"I don't care.
"I'm an artist.
"I don't need it."
But this is my business
now, and it is important.
My agent always says I'm his only client
that ever calls him back as soon as he,
because it's my business,
and I respect my business.
- [Charlie] Your agent
says you're his only client
that calls him back to say--
- Immediately.
- If I have a missed call,
I'm probably the only,
I return emails, I return
phone calls because--
- [Charlie] Because you want
to know what options there are.
- Yes, I've worked really
hard to build this,
and I want to continue building it,
and it's my business,
my personal business,
so I don't understand how people do slack.
- I'm really annoying
with how I choose things,
'cause it's really like a feeling,
which just sounds stupid,
but sometimes I've read
scripts before that have...
I just recently have read a
script that I was sobbing.
I've never been so moved by a story,
and I thought it was the most
beautiful, amazing story.
And I just couldn't wait
for this movie to get made
so that the world could see it,
but I just wasn't her,
I wasn't the character,
and I couldn't.
And I also had an experience once
where I read the script and I loved it,
but I couldn't stop
picturing Amanda Seyfried,
and so I emailed the
people and I was like,
"You got to hire Amanda
Seyfried for this."
I couldn't stop picturing it.
So a lot of it is the things that he said,
you want to be part of a good film
and you want to make a good movie,
but there's also a huge
emotional component for me
that I don't know how to describe it.
It's just kind of
sometimes something clicks
and I feel like that person does
in a weird way exist in me,
and it sounds like a stupid thing to say,
and sometimes it just doesn't,
and sometimes I can read a character
and absolutely love her,
but I know that I could never,
I'm not her or something,
I don't know.
- [Interviewer] So how was the experience
of being directed by David finally?
- Oh, a dream come true,
'cause when you're such
a huge fan of somebody
you build it up so much
and you're always prepared to be let down,
but he was just the nicest,
warmest, sweetest person
in the entire world,
just has such a warm, good energy,
and then he just directs in this,
I've never worked that way,
and that's such an incredible thing to do
is to kind of realize that
there's no one or right way
to make a movie or direct an actor.
- [Interviewer] So did he do something
that you particularly liked
that you haven't done?
- Yeah, he would interrupt
like any monologue,
no matter what it was, no
matter how serious, he would go,
"Oh, it's such bullshit.
"It's so bad, it's so bad." (laughs)
I'd be like, "Alright, let's do it again."
It's just like so funny
to be able to like,
because you can be honest
like on this whole new level.
That's why Bradley and I don't
want to stop working together,
because we can just be
like, "Don't say that.
"Don't wear that.
"What are you doing?"
Just boss each other around.
Yeah, I like him not wasting time
and just like cutting the bullshit,
and just getting real,
'cause I feel like everybody
always treats actors like,
as they probably should,
emotional like landmines,
everybody is like tip toeing around
'cause you never know what's
going to set them off.
It's just a job like any other.
Sometimes you're going to be good,
and sometimes you're going to be bad.
I like it when somebody
is like, "That was bad.
"Do it again."
- [Interviewer] So when he's saying that
he's saying it mostly about
you guys, not about his script?
- No, it's never about a script.
It's always about our
performance. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] You just missed the mark.
- Yeah no, it'll just be like,
"You were really bad."
The scariest part of my job
is the gamble of reading a script.
Which one do you do?
Who makes it?
You never know.
You can read an amazing script
and hire a director who seems fantastic,
and have an amazing co star,
and you can be on set and
be completely out of control
and watch it either fall apart,
or you can love it
and then audiences don't respond,
and then there is planning of a year.
You know, if you're going
to have this movie come out,
what follows that, and then what?
And that's the most
stressful part of my job,
'cause it is a gamble,
but it's important to me that
I do make those decisions.
I don't want an agent's
career or a lawyer's career.
I need advice.
I have an amazing agent and
I really respect his opinion,
but I would never do...
My entire career is dictated by a feeling,
and I've gone through great lengths
to try and make sure
that it stays that way.
I've shed big parts of my team,
'cause I don't want more
people to say no to.
- [Charlie] You trust your gut?
- I do, and sometimes I'm wrong.
- And when you're wrong,
what do you think happens?
- Everything is fine, it happens.
In business there's ups and downs.
I would much rather blame
myself though than go,
"I shouldn't have
listened to that person."
At least I go, "Well, you learned."
- You know why you made the choice
even if it turned out
to be the wrong choice.
- Yeah.
- But when I just started
and I had no idea what I was doing,
I didn't what else to do,
I didn't know how to act,
I just knew how to talk,
and I think once I started
understanding I was like,
"Well, I don't really
want to learn how to act.
"I just want to keep
learning how to talk."
And I've always just been
such a people studier
that I think that for me
the best schooling I
could have ever gotten
was watching and listening to the world.
I mean just watching people talk,
watching people do different things.
So many of the things that I do on screen
are things that I've seen other people do
that I thought were interesting.
you know, like funny things
with people's mouths,
or when they're upset the
things they do with their hands.
Like this one time my friend was crying
and she was so upset.
She put her hands up
and she didn't know what to do with them
and they were just shaking.
And I was comforting her,
but at the same time I was like,
"That's kind of cool." (laughs)
- Do it again, do it again, yeah.
- Yes, yeah, I know.
It was like, "What did
you do right there?"
So I had an emotional
scene in The Poker House
and almost every time I cried
I did that with my hands,
and I don't know, I just
pick up from people.
- Having experienced the body
image criticism in Hollywood,
what is your advice to young girls
dealing with the same
treatment from their peers,
and response to those who judge
others based on appearances?
- Well screw those people.
(audience laughs)
- No, and it--
(applause)
Oh, thanks. (laughs)
Yeah, I mean it's something
that everybody experiences.
I experienced it in school
before I was famous.
The world has a certain idea of,
you know, we see this
airbrushed perfect model,
and then if you don't
look like that, you're..
And it's just too easy for people.
I've got a million ideas
coming at the same time,
but you just have to look past it.
You look how you look, and be comfortable.
Like what are you going to
do, be hungry every single day
to make other people happy?
That's just dumb.
And the shows like the Fashion
Police and things like that
are just showing these
generations of young people
to judge people based on things,
they put values on all
the things that are wrong,
and that it's okay to just point at people
and call them ugly and call them fat,
and they call it fun, and
welcome to the real world,
and it's like that
shouldn't be the real world.
It's going to keep being the real
world if we keep it that way.
It's not until we stop
treating each other like that,
and just stop calling each other fat,
and stop with these unrealistic
expectations for women.
It's disappointing that
the media keeps it alive
and fuels that fire.
It's something that really bothers me,
because I love to eat.
- What does it take to be a great actress?
'Cause that performance in your movie
is a really great performance
I think by any yardstick.
What does she have, Jennifer,
that takes it to that
kind of level? (laughs)
- I think there's a soulfulness
that's immediately there.
It's right there in her eyes
and in her face and in her,
the way she talks.
I don't know how to express it
except just to point to her performance.
I mean, she has a soulfulness
that comes from her,
and there's...
I don't want to embarrass her
or sound, I just think people...
We were concerned she was
too young for the role,
and I said she almost has
a timeless quality to her,
which I do feel.
I feel like sometimes
she seems like she's 18,
sometimes she seems like she's 40.
And not only that, a realness.
There's a lack of preciousness.
There's not a frame
around what she's doing.
It's raw and it's real,
and it comes from part of her soul,
and she just channels it right out there.
She's not afraid to jump in and do it
any number of different ways,
and she has very good instincts.
She'll tell you when she
feels something is false
and when she'd like to
find another way to do it.
But it's a great gift to a
director to have an actor
who has so much emotion
readily available in their face
that's authentic emotion.
It's from her, and it's a part of her.
I just don't know how...
It's a blessing to have
someone channel that.
- [Diane] And she's already
created a kind of legacy
to be bold in your life.
There was a girl she met
on the first Hunger Games,
a burn survivor who had
scars all over her body.
- She's said, "I love my body,
"because I'm the girl on fire."
It made her feel strong and brave,
and I just started crying,
'cause she gave me such a gift.
And I'm just acting,
but it made me feel like
if a character or a story
could make somebody change
a perception on how they
feel about themselves,
then that is beautiful.
- [Diane] For a generation
of tiny fans, one message,
believe in yourself.
- I grew up on a horse farm,
so I rode a lot of horses,
which I hear you like horses.
- Yeah, I do, I like horses.
- I hear you hate horses.
- What, no, are you drunk?
(audience laughs)
- No, it just, it would've
been a very weird thing
to hate horses.
- No, I don't hate--
- They're so likeable.
- I like 'em, but you ride them, right?
- Yeah, I do.
- You ever fallen off or been thrown?
- Yeah, 'cause my parents were cheap,
so they never bought trained horses.
(audience laughs)
So it was just kind of...
I have a deformed tailbone, actually,
from being thrown off of a horse.
- You know, I'd heard that.
(audience laughs)
Now wait a minute, you're
telling me that your parents
bought wild, unbroken stallions
because they were cheaper
and let the kids loose on 'em?
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, they were busy.
They had more things to worry about.
- They were busy, of course!
So then you had to break your own horse.
- Yeah, or my own tailbone.
- And were you tossed or kicked?
- Everything.
At one point the horse
was running into a barn,
like an abandoned barn,
so I had to just jump
ship and drop and roll.
That was the deformed elbow.
(audience laughs)
- In Kentucky, did they
ride Western or English?
- I sound like such a redneck.
I didn't really ride with a saddle.
(audience laughs)
We had English and Western saddles,
but my mom said that
that was for the people
who like board their horses there,
so I wasn't allowed to use any of that,
so I just kind of hopped
on and went for it.
- Good idea.
(audience laughs)
Did anybody from the county
ever come out to the house?
(Jennifer laughs)
(audience laughs)
Talk to Mom and Dad about--
- I'm going to get my parents arrested.
My childhood in my mind seems so lovely
and just picturesque,
and then I talk back about
it I'm like, "Oh my God."
- You did stay away from them saddles.
Now get out there and break them broncs!
- That's for the ranch folk.
(Dave laughs)
- Yeah, (mumbles) is for rich people.
- Oh my goodness, yeah.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
MrPlaythroughs101 asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what
did you take from this video?
What did Jennifer say that
had the biggest impact on you
that you're going to
make an immediate change
to your business or your life?
Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the conversation.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Kemo Tedajo.
Thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
and taking that awesome
picture with the Eiffel Tower.
I really, really, really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(swoosh)
- Yeah, I mean I was very fortunate.
I started trying to work at 14,
and I got on a sitcom when I was 16.
I dealt with a lot of nos,
mostly personal nos within my family.
It's hard for a 14 year old to say,
"I'm leaving Kentucky.
"I'm moving to New York."
But I knew I felt so strongly.
It feels insane to be a teenager and know.
I knew that it was the right thing to do.
I knew that it was going to work out.
- What did they say?
- Well, "No."
I wouldn't be supportive
if my teenager was like,
"I'm moving to New York."
They thought I was going to get killed.
I'm surprised I didn't get killed.
But it was like this fire,
and also I just knew it.
So I eventually saved up babysitting money
and went and did it.
- [Interviewer] So what as the first time
you felt really challenged
to come up with something
that was that much harder to do for you?
- What do you mean?
- [Interviewer] Well, I mean it seems like
something like The Burning
Plain for instance,
it's a really tough role.
It's not a, you know,
"I came up.
"(mumbles) found me in
the street of New York
"and told me to be an
actress and here I am."
- Yeah.
- Or was it?
I mean was it just that natural to you?
- It was.
I think it actually helped me,
'cause I didn't really go to any classes
or theater schools or anything like that,
so I didn't really know how to act.
I just knew how to talk,
and then I just knew...
I don't know.
I think I was able to
build my instincts better,
and I learned from a lot of mistakes.
I can look back on things now and be like,
"Well, at least you learned from that."
I don't know, I think it was...
It's so hard for me to answer
'cause I haven't thought about it
as much as you guys have. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] That's probably true.